[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
c'est bien chez vous oui ça fait une île
ça va mais nulle où il ya deux pieds oui
non ça va ça s'est bien passé qu'est ce
qu'on fait chez vous alors je vais
t'expliquer ça j'espère qu'un je me
ferai comprendre parce que c'est un peu
compliqué mais en plus il faut que j'y
aille très vite bien alors je vous
propose moi d'inventer un feuilleton un
feuilleton comme vous en voyez parfois
la télévision une histoire quand vous
enliser dans des bandes dessinées ou
d'une histoire comme vous la voyez au
cinéma qu'est ce que ça veut dire une
histoire ça veut dire des personnages
une intrigue des rebondissements du
suspense enfin tout ce que vous voulez
vous avez tous les droits vous serez les
auteurs de cette histoire du début à la
fin
bien voilà pour le cadre général comment
allons nous procéder
il faut dire qu'on aurait bien aimé vous
avoir tous ici mais pour des raisons
évidentes ce n'est pas possible
alors on va vous téléphonez à vous
téléphoner c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui nous aurons un certain
nombre d'entre vous au téléphone car ils
nous ont déjà envoyé leur carte postale
avec leur numéro
ceux qui veulent jouer la prochaine fois
je voudrais l'adresse en fin d'émission
tout à l'heure maintenant je voudrais
vous présenter la petite équipe que vous
retrouverez ainsi tous les quinze jours
dans marabout de ficelle d'abord
isabelle isabelle va nous aider à
inscrire ce tableau toutes les
propositions que vous allez faire qu'est
ce que c'est qu'une proposition quand
nous allons commencer à jouer d'ici
quelques minutes vous allez me dire bon
moi j'aimerais que cette histoire se
passe dans l endroit avec tel personnage
bon alors si les petits enfants qui sont
là à côté de moi qui sont le jury si
cette proposition leur plaît isabelle
l'écrit avec votre nom à côté cet accord
bon isabelle comment vois-tu procédé
pour ce soit clair j'ai inscrit le nom
de l'enfant et on abréger ses idées on
abrégé alors ne soyez pas surpris si on
comprend pas toujours tout ça vous dire
que c'est pas un prêt il ya autre
personnage important de cette émission
c'est cabu alors qu'à bus était un
dessinateur incitateur que vous
connaissez peut-être si vous avez les
pilotes ou si vous lisez un autre
magazine satirique qui paraît le
mercredi cabu un personnage paraît jeudi
pardon un personnage très connu qui
appelle le grand duduche savez grand
duduche ça monsieur
regardez si vous regardez oui le voilà
et si on regarde et cabu d'ailleurs vous
serez pas surpris de voir que à peu de
choses près c'est un peu le même
personnage voilà alors qu'à but qu'est
ce qu'il va faire pour nous eh bien il
va vous aider il à vous aider car lui a
déjà écrit des scénarii connais la bande
dessinée parfaitement c'est écrire une
histoire alors on aura besoin de ses
lumières
et puis en plus ces sectes qui est
important c'est que chaque fois que vous
aurez une idée de personnages un petit
droit lunettes un grand mec avec une
grande mèche et bain capital décidée lui
il va vous aider à le visualiser à le
matérialiser d'accord bon cabut vous
avez votre place avec vos crayons et
votre papier alors voilà aussi autres
notre jury alors ils sont pas très
nombreux aujourd'hui et puis vous avez
mis avec des garçons bon alors c'est
vrai ya que des garçons aujourd'hui mais
il faut dire que au téléphone vous allez
voir tout à l'heure on aura beaucoup de
petites filles
alors comme ça s'équilibre bon je crois
qu'on peut commencer
alors ce jury ce jury je vais tomber
dans l'île ce jury est chargé chargé de
quoi il est une mission importante c'est
que quand nous aurons écrit toutes nos
propositions au tableau bien falloir
choisir
c'est pas moi qui vais choisir ses packs
abus c'est pas isabelle ce sont les
enfants qui vont choisir
voilà si bien que d'ici 14 15 minutes on
aura une proposition nous aurons retenu
dans quinze jours nouvel épisode 2 de
l'émission on commencera à partir de la
proposition d'aujourd'hui
tout ça est un peu compliqué c'est la
première fois sobiz est obligé d'aller
vite mais vous allez voir c'est assez
simple si vous voulez on va commencer
tout de suite avec quelqu'un au
téléphone allô allô oui bonjour moi je
m'appelle willy tu t'appelles comment tu
le dis je le dis tu habites ou dans le
tarn et garonne qu'elle était lui
demande ta ville petit village petit
village pour quel âge as-tu bon alors
écoute que d'y jouer comme tu la
première qui débute cette émission c'est
toi qui va essuyer les plâtres
comme on dit alors pour t d un peu parce
que sur notre table il n'y a rien il
nous faut des personnages il nous faut
des décors il faut plein de choses il
nous faut des lieux il nous faut une
intrigue alors on n'a rien et toi tu
commence alors je te proposer un canevas
en gros 1
si tu veux
il nous faut des personnages qui sont
des enfants des adultes
à toi de choisir les enfants c'est sûr
bon dit non mais tu veux on va pas faire
question il répond c'est faux que il
faut que tu es tu aussi tu penses à
plein de choses bon je te le dis
rapidement en gros tu me diras après un
alors des enfants qui habitent à la
ville ou à la campagne c'est une
histoire qui se passe pendant la classe
ou qui se passe en pub scolaire ou à
cheval comme tu veux c'est une histoire
qui se passe aujourd'hui ou dans
l'ancien temps c'est une histoire qui se
passe en france ou à l'étranger
bon alors maintenant je t'écoute alors
on va commencer par le début si tu veux
tu veux que ce soit des enfants beaucoup
d'enfants ont pas beaucoup
comment au coude enfants trois garçons
et deux filles
ce sont des enfants qui ont quel âge a
baissé c'est bien qu'il y avait pensé
avant alors trois garçons deux filles en
calant ils habitent tous ces garçons ça
ce sont nos personnages principaux je
t'entends pas bien excuse-moi claudie
inaudible ils n'habitent pas sur cette
planète
il habite seule sur la planète
y'a plus personne mais pourquoi qu'est
ce qui s'est passé c'est gai ton truc ça
commence bien
alors on commence par la bombe commis on
commence par rien quoi on veut commencer
une histoire et toi tu l'a finie bon
alors écoute on va noter on verra bien
ce que diront aux 4 go sont pas
convaincus on va noter à leurs bombes
atomiques appui personne sauf trois
garçons et deux filles
bah oui alors c'est plus la peine de
chercher si ça se passe en france sur
l'étranger c'est réglé bon tu as une
autre une autre proposition à me faire
pour s'être pour ce début d'histoire
comment tu la vois la suite parce que si
on commence par la bombe atomique s'est
compromis une suite non comment tu vois
la suite à cela ils sont trois garçons
deux filles
ils sont dans une dans une ville c'est
ça
google dans une cité futuriste en forme
de dôme
quand ça se passe bien après la fin de
ce siècle alors comment ça se passe
après l'emprunt en 2000 en 2004 avait
cette histoire de science fiction
bon écoute que dis je te remercie
j'espère que cette proposition plaira
notre jury car je te rappelle à tous à
tous les autres enfants qui veulent
jouer tous ceux qui habitent la province
et dont on gardera la proposition tout
au moins celui dont on gardera la
proposition sera invité à participer ici
en direct en paris l émission d'accord
c'est bien retenu st donc il faut que
juillet nombreux merci que le dis au
revoir au revoir
alors ça vous plaît ou ça vous plaît pas
là le jury
ça vous plaît bien le futur vous
préférez pas une histoire contemporaine
avec des personnages d'aujourd'hui ou
une histoire avec chez pas moi au
moyen-âge moyenâgeux c'est pas
maintenant on va voir en tout cas ça se
savent à quelqu'un d'autre au téléphone
allô oui bonjour comment tu t'appelles
comment christine bonjour qui est-il bon
peu tu as vu ce que claudine nous a
proposé est ce que tu abonde dans son
sens où tu veux quelque chose de très
différent alors vas-y je t'écoute
ben oui si tu avais une toute prête moi
je t'écoute
ça m'évitera de refaire la liste alors
[Musique]
j'en fais trop ça s'appelle j'entends
très mal christine bon ça s'appelle
dernier trop bon alors vas-y
[Musique]
christine tu veux pas la résumer ton
histoire parce que j'ai l'impression que
tu la lie sur un bout de papier
ah oui alors en compte la mois en gros
quoi c'est une histoire il ya des
garçons des filles ça se passe où avec
des garçons oui attends attends rares
isabelle va marquer alors des garçons
aient eu combien à 12 c'est pas plus ni
moins alors 12 et est un qui arrive
bon alors 12 garçons et 1 dont on ne
sait par shepard est une fille un
fourre-tout alors dans un petit village
si mes petits villages ça se passe en
france à l'heure actuelle
à notre époque de mathusalem
tu savais ce qui se passait à l'époque
de mathusalem ah bon niçois qui t'a plu
bon alors ça se passe il ya très très
longtemps ses personnages bibliques
mathusalem et sa commun c'est un
personnage de la bible mathusalem loup
bon bah écoute on va voir déjà on a
quelques indications
je te remercie christine on va passer à
quelqu'un d'autre d'accord bien au
revoir christine merci bon on va
peut-être jouer avec les les garçons et
les filles de nogent ils ont plein
d'autres idées en tout cas ils sont
vraisemblablement plus âgés que ceux que
nous en avons eu au téléphone
nogent oui france vous avez est-ce que
vous avez des gens pleins d'imagination
autour de vous en tout cas ils ont l'air
plein d'imagination et sont fous de joie
ils ont déjà commencé à construire une
histoire tous ensemble on râle et le
premier qui vous voulez alors cet homme
à qui ça se passerait dans un monde
ailleurs dans un autre monde dans notre
galaxie avec un monde dirigé par les
enfants eux ont oublié que la nature
aucun immeuble aucune centrale n'a rien
ôté norman bon attendons mal on va noter
sa thomas alors un monde
de l'avenir alors les enfants sont un
peu l'hérault à la ba oui ça servait bon
quelqu'un d'autre daniel je crois oui
c'est vrai non je voudrais quand même 6
1 il était une fois alors une fois il
était autrefois c'est ça peut-être nom
où ils seraient une fois il serait une
fois vas-y à pour aller aussi
alors ce qu'il a dit là dans un autre
monde sait bien et bon alors il faudrait
que ce soit ouvert ouvert alors attends
maintenant on va quand même se tourner
vers cabu diakhaby tu peux montrer ton
mathusalem que pour faire plaisir à
christine voilà que la vie nous a
distillé un mathusalem sais pas si on va
le garder
voilà qui suit une sorte de mathusalem
mais attendez j'ai commencé par là
l'histoire la voile à lorient tu attends
plus infects a vu tout petit peu voilà
je vais proposer aux enfants de nos gens
de regarder les trois personnages vous
savez les trois survivants là est-ce
qu'ils ont des têtes qui vous semble
sympathique est ce qu'on pourra les
garder cela pour notre cité futuriste
par exemple si on regarde assis ses
futurs hits jalons du toit oui ou non
vite
non non non lequel vous n'aimez pas si
droite assez calé dans un peu comme ça
n'avait pas les gens qui ont les dents
écartées
j'ai pris pour modèle le jury et vous
vous les aimez vous le jure il a les
trois petits garçons
bon peut-être et garder alors bon pour
cette cité futuriste là pour cette cité
future et c'est ce que c'est l'unanimité
chez vous à nogent en france c'est très
important c'est l'impression mais ils
ont des personnages très bizarre vous
proposait alors annoncé qu'un but est
prêt au moins vivre un vampire avant
clients voir si on peut faire ça ensuite
les six espaces en pleine nuit qui a pas
de soleil alors oui bah ça on si vous
voulez bien on fera des des nuits des
jours déjà après midi un roi on va tout
faire la nuit enfin si les gages très
nette sens où vous voulez que ça se
passe
après l'an 2000 sachets curieux n'a pas
un d'entre vous qui souhaiteraient que
ça se passe aujourd'hui à notre époque
mais je crois qu'il y avait ici à nogent
c'était rappelle oui raphaël je t'écoute
raphaël qu'est ce que tu voulais tu nous
avais parlé d'une autre histoire
libye et ben non je voulais une histoire
dans le futur mais c'est pas grave mais
c'était une histoire de quel genre à les
vitres afin de nous en a parlé tout à
l'heure dans une histoire romantique
c'est un truc comme à rome antique
d'amérique un drame quand même avec un
drap tu veux dire l histoire d'amour
référions il aime quelqu'un d'autre quoi
bruit violent ils des gens qui meurent
aussi
ça peut arriver enfin je vais vous
signaler quand même qu'on va éviter
on va éviter de faire des choses trop
violente et moi a priori je me disais ça
serait bien si on a vite si on est en
inventer un un feuilleton un peu drôle
mais vraiment marrant et puis elle à
l'an 2000 chez passé manche connaît pas
on verra bien bon alors une histoire
d'amour cabu tu nous feras des gens qui
s'aiment si tu as le temps
voilà un vampire façon cabut alors c'est
un des personnages attention cette
importance qui vous fait à but parce que
si vous les aimez ces personnages si le
jury d'accord on les garde on les met de
côté ils joueront dans notre histoire
d'accord quelqu un de nos propositions à
nogent daniel je crois oui venir je
reprends le vampire d'olivier py ça se
passerait dans un vieux château et dans
des souterrains du château
ah bon alors ça c'est plus du tout l'an
2000 alors un château qui seraient vieux
pour l'heure 2000
mais maintenant c'est un truc moderne
quoi pour m ap ap on attend explique toi
bon enfin tu sais toujours l'an 2000 de
toute façon un on est d'accord
ouais bon ça c'est compliqué bon le jury
maintenant on fait un petit d une petite
incursion ici qu'est ce que vous en
pensez tout ça comment
pas lui pourquoi vous n'avez pas les
vampires à bangalore là il ya au futur
vous n'êtes pas d'accord tu important
notre jury n'est pas d'accord sur les
histoires de vampires
alors donc on n'est pas sûr aujourd'hui
qu'on garde de l'an 2000 donc vous en
douter d'y aller parce qu'un la loire
plusieurs émissions pour choisir quelle
époque à une deux ou trois ans on verra
bien mais c'est important parce qu'une
fois on sera dans l'an 2000 au moyen-âge
ou maintenant c'est fini on peut plus
revenir en arrière
attention on est bien d'accord or il me
reste du temps il faut que je conclus il
y en a beaucoup d'entre vous que j'ai
pas pu que j'ai pas pu avoir au
téléphone aujourd'hui pour des raisons
évidentes vous avez vu on est assez
nombreux et là même qui ont raccroché
on est assez nombreux et il faut que
tout le monde joue alors la prochaine
fois ce que je n'ai pas pu avoir au
téléphone je leur téléphonerait qui
désespère pas en jours ensemble dans
quinze jours et n'oubliez pas ce qu'ils
veulent participer à ce jeu envoyez nous
une carte postale à l'adresse suivante
marabout de ficelle
vous allez la lire en même temps moi si
tout va bien enfin je la connais par
coeur je peux vous la dire marabout de
ficelle 5 7 rue de montessuy paris 75
341 c'est ça paris cedex 07
alors on veut une carte postale nom
prénom âge et surtout surtout numéro de
téléphone et n'oubliez pas celui qui
aura la meilleure proposition et qui
habite à provins et invité la semaine
prochaine
moi je crois que de toute façon la
proposition de la cité futuriste et qui
s'était claudie apparemment aujourd'hui
c'est ce qui a été gardé un la cité
futuriste c'est ce que tout le monde
était d'accord sur cité futuriste comme
il nous faut quelqu'un invités bachelot
dit tiens tu viendras dans quinze jours
faire partie du jury
d'accord je me sens je vous dis au
revoir merci d'avoir joué avec nous
avant 15 jours
salut à tous
[Musique]